So, what are some of the
world's oldest institutions?
One of the oldest companies that we know
of is a temple construction
company called Kongo Gumi
which was started at the end
of the sixth century, at least.
And it's still operating today.
Now, I believe it's been subsumed
by a larger construction conglomerate
but they're still building temples
and still largely the same
kind of operations and staff.
One of the oldest hotels in
the world, also in Japan,
the Nishiyama Onsen Keiunkan,
kind of a Japanese homestay,
still in operation today.
One of the oldest restaurants
in the world built
in a little after 800 A.D.
is the Stiftskeller St. Peter
Hotel and Restaurant.
One of the oldest wineries that we know of
in the world, interestingly,
is the Staffelter Hof winery
in Germany built in 862,
as far as we know.
Some of the other types of businesses
and operations that we start to see
over a millennia ago that
are still in operation
are bars and pubs.
So, Sean's bar in Ireland is said
to have been built in 900 A.D.
The other thing that we start to see
in the 11th century is the invention
and proliferation of universities.
So we have things like
the University of Bologna
and soon afterwards, the
University of Oxford, and then many
of the other universities
in the UK and other parts
of Europe really start to proliferate.
More recently we are seeing
some more commodity type things
like the Poland Salt Mines in Wieliczka,
starting in the 13th century.
And then even paper companies
like the Stora Enso
Finnish paper company in 1288.
But you'll notice that not only are many
of the oldest organizations
in the world in certain areas like Japan
and the old world of Europe,
but also there tend to be a ton
of breweries, winemakers, confectionaries,
and some cases, hotels,
organizations that
serve basic human needs.
One of the other things that
you start to see when you look
at aggregates of companies
that's, for instance, lasts
for more than 200 years of
huge majority area in Japan.
So this idea that location matters,
even though Japan has risen
and fallen and had lost wars,
their basic system of government
and culture has lasted over time.
And the other places, like
old-world Europe in Germany
and Holland and France are
some of the other places
that we see some of the
longest-lived institutions.